♪ Chumba-wumba,
hubba-bubba, Ray Liotta ♪
Greetings, Shit For Brain,
Dances With Rhythm,
Morning After,
and Gay Buffalo.
Big Chief Horsedick
come bearing big news.
15 years after being
shut down,
we're finally reopening
Camp Brickleberry,
and you're all gonna be
camp counselors.
- Yes!
Woody, this park is
a dangerous place for children.
So is your uterus.
Jackubowski
wants the camp reopened.
And it gives
the park a chance
to make a buttload of money
off some sucker parents.
So you sure as shit
better show them a good time.
So we're supposed to chase
these kids around
and do all this extra work?
What do we get?
Well, the counselor
whose tribe is voted the best
at the end of the week wins...
[imitates fanfare]
the legendary tribal shield.
Like anyone with a brain
could be motivated
by a painted trash can lid.
- I'm winning this!
- No, it's mine!
Hands off
my painted trash can lid!
Settle down, morons!
Put these on.
Woody, I, uh,
didn't get a shirt.
There's no way I'm letting you
be a counselor again.
You're the reason we had
to close the camp
in the first place.
What happened?
I remember it like it happened
15 years ago.
- Steve?
- Oh, sorry.
I thought you guys
could see my brain movie.
Every summer the entire camp
would compete against each other
in the mother of all
camp competitions--
The Gauntlet.
[gunshot]
[grunts]
- We're gonna lose.
- I know a shortcut.
Are you sure
about this?
This sign says
"mine field."
Mine field, your field,
I don't care whose field it is.
Get in there!
[explosions]
This is gonna make
for a scary brain movie.